When we communicate, we not only
communicate our ideas, we communicate
our identity. My name is Matt Abrahams
and I teach strategic communication at
Stamford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast Talks Smart the
podcast.
Today I look forward [music] to speaking
with Peter Novak. Peter is a former vice
provost at the University of San
Francisco and former dean at Yale
University. He is the founder of the
Strictly Speaking Group. Peter leverages
his doctorate and background in
linguistics and acting [music] to help
non-native speakers master clear
communication. He has an award-winning
LinkedIn learning course on public
speaking for non-native English
speakers. Welcome, Peter. I am really
excited to bring you to the show and to
share what you've shared with my
students uh here with everybody. Thanks
for joining.
>> Thanks so much. I've been so looking
forward to this conversation.
>> All right. Should we get started?
>> Absolutely.
>> Great. On the show, we've often spoken
about how word choice affects the
strength of our messages and the
impressions people form of us. Your work
highlights the impact accents can have
on people's perceptions. Can you share a
bit about this? Uh, and please make sure
you define what you mean by accent bias
because I think this is really important
for what we'll talk about today.
Absolutely. Let me start with the
definition of accent bias. So accent
bias is essentially that reflex that we
have to trust people who sound like us.
>> And and this happens a lot with people
who are the inroup and people who are
part of the out group. The idea of
accent bias of who's in and who's out uh
and what that means it it really affects
the workplace too. Uh it can affect
hiring decisions. It can affect
promotion decisions. It often affects
how people feel about u leadership
qualities. Uh and so all of these
aspects of accent bias creep into uh our
workplace without us really
understanding or knowing uh the full
impact of it.
>> We could have uh our career and our
trajectories be affected by something we
don't even know.
>> That's right. Have you found that there
are advantages to having an an accent or
that non-native speakers bring to their
communication maybe through the focus of
of the specific words or the way they
speak versus those who who
>> don't have an accent in in a given
environment
>> or or who don't have the the accent of
the majority in the specific group.
Absolutely. And I I love the framing of
this question around the advantages that
non-native speakers have because so
often
>> they come to the table thinking it's a
disadvantage to have an accent when
they're speaking. And and so I I think
what's fun about that is that um when
you think about multilingual speakers,
75% of people in the US and Canada and
Australia and Great Britain don't speak
another language.
And so when you've got multilingual
speakers, their skills in being able to
code switch between language and
cultures, uh, in being able to be more
intentional, um, which is part of your
question, I think about that focus that
they have about the language choice that
they're having is really, really
profound. And I think it's up to native
speakers to recognize that non-native
speakers are doing a hell of a lot more
work, right,
>> in the workplace than native speakers
are. We tend to take our proficiency in
English for granted. We don't think
about how we use it. We don't think
about ways to use it more clearly for
non-native speakers. And and I like to
say remember Ginger Rogers and Fred aair
uh the dancers from the 1940s and 50s.
Everyone said that Ginger Rogers did
everything Fred a stair did only
backwards and in high heels, right?
>> And in many ways that's what non-native
speakers are doing too. They are in the
moment involved sometimes in translating
what was said into their first language.
Oftentimes translating what they want to
say from their first language or another
language. Um thinking about tone,
thinking about word choice, thinking
about all these other things that native
speakers don't have to. And I think we
need to give them credit for that and
then create the structures around that
that enable a [snorts] greater
linguistic flexibility in the workplace.
>> Yeah. And just just recognizing that
that the difference even exists and that
you and that you should take the time to
to reflect and accommodate. I have found
that that the folks I know who speak
multiple languages, some of whom who
have accents and some who don't, their
ability to listen and discern subtlety
is is far superior to mine. Uh really
interesting.
>> Agreed.
>> I have heard you say in my class and in
things you've written, it's not an
accent, it's an identity. What do you
mean by this? And and how can it help
someone who is concerned about their
accent to reframe it in this way?
>> Sure. You know, language carries with it
uh culture. Uh it carries identity. It
carries individual stories.
And so why would we want to try and fix
that? There's no reason to to really fix
that. The goal actually is is clarity.
And I I think sometimes there was a
great episode of Modern Family with
Evaong Eva Longoria. was that who who
said do you even know how smart I am in
Spanish? [laughter]
And this is what happens if you ask a
multilingual speaker. Do they feel like
different personality traits emerge with
the different languages that they speak?
They will say absolutely. I am so much
funnier in my first language and I don't
have access to the same type of comedy
uh in English or in a second language
that I do in my first. And so really
there's this interesting part of
identity that shifts because of the
different languages that we speak. And I
I think that needs to be celebrated. It
needs to be brought into the the
workspace a lot more uh than it normally
is.
>> Yeah. You you just reminded me uh I was
coaching a very senior leader of an
institution we all know uh who was a
native French speaker
>> and in English he was a little more
stilted, a little more buttoned up. But
when I actually had him say the same
thing in French, he became much more
lively, much more connected, and we were
able to use that as a tool, as a guide
to to allow him to feel more free
speaking in English. It really is
interesting how we have these different
compartmentalizations based on language.
Uh before I ask you to share some
specific techniques uh that those with
accents can take to feel more confident
in their communication, I'd love to ask
you to define some foundational
principles that I know you you refer
back to. And in fact, these principles
apply not just to people who are
speaking in a language other than their
native language. They apply to all of
us. So can you help us understand what
you mean by processing fluency,
>> intelligibility
and comprehensibility?
>> Abs. Absolutely. So in a nutshell,
processing fluency is the ease with
which we understand something. And I
think the goal of every speaker is to
try and make what they say as easy as
possible to understand for the listener
uh for your audience, whoever that
audience is. And it really means getting
to know your audience as well as
possible. And so uh processing fluency
is is essentially that. Processing
disfluency is anything that gets in the
way of that message being understood.
That could be content, right? You ramble
or you don't have a good structure,
right? Or it could be delivery. Um,
right? Things that make it difficult for
people to hear and understand.
>> And that brings us to the linguistic
ideas around intelligibility and
comprehensibility.
Intelligibility is how much I understand
of what you say. Right?
Comprehensibility is how hard I have to
work to understand you. It's the effort
that I put into understanding you. Let
me put this into an example. Let's say
you're on a Zoom call. It's a little
glitchy on the other end, but maybe you
understand what the person said, but
still there was I'm losing you a little
bit and so you have to work harder to do
it. That's the difference between
intelligibility and comprehensibility.
Right? And the best part about this is
that there were major studies done 20
years ago and more that say that people
who speak English as a second, third or
fourth language can improve both their
intelligibility and their
comprehensibility
with no noticeable shift in accent.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> Exactly.
>> Wow.
>> Exactly. And so there are some really
interesting things to focus on to help
you do that without worrying about what
your accent really is. Processing
fluency is the ease with which we take
in the information. That's right. And
there's a whole bunch of things we can
do. Making sure we know our audience so
it it's easier for them. We're using
relevant concepts and ideas that they
can connect to. Structuring the
information, making it more concise. And
then intelligibility is the
understanding and the comprehensibility
is how hard we work to understand that.
That's right. And anything we can do to
reduce comprehensibility, I would
assume, helps with processing fluency.
>> Absolutely.
>> Excellent. Yep. So, let's get very
tactical and practical. Uh, what are
some techniques and approaches you
recommend to help people who want to
work on their accents or increase their
intelligibility uh while not increasing
the comprehensibility of what they're
saying?
>> Yeah. Yeah. While while they want to do
both, they want to have both high
intelligibility and high
comprehensibility. Okay. Um, and so and
so what I would say is that that the
goal is clarity. That's number one.
First and foremost, the goal is clarity.
>> So, clarity of of meaning.
>> Clarity of meaning, right? And then
clarity also of delivery. I see. And and
what that mean
>> I clearly undererstood you but I also
clearly heard you.
>> That's right.
>> Okay. Very good.
>> And so so there was an interesting study
from McGill University in Canada and
basically it said this. Your car breaks
down in a um city that you don't know
very well. Uh [snorts] and your phone is
out of juice and so you're trying to
find a garage that you can go to. And so
you ask the first person, they tell you
to go one direction. You ask a second
person. The first person is a native
speaker. sounds like you,
>> right?
>> You ask a second person, they tell you
to go in the opposite direction and they
have an outgroup speech or accent,
right? Right. Foreign or something you
don't recognize. Who are you going to
trust more? And in essence, the study
found that you trust people who sound
like you more. That's what accent bias
is. However, if the person who speaks
with a different accent than your own
speaks with confidence, then it reduces
that gap. I see. And so the question
becomes,
what does speaking in English with
confidence actually mean?
What are people who speak English as
their first language listening for that
tells us that that person is confident?
We know this. We know what some of those
elements are.
>> Yes.
>> Uh and and some of them are all related
to proity. So proity is is an element of
speech that thinks about the musicality
of the language which thinks about um
volume and pacing and the power that you
lend to certain words and inflection.
It's all of the things outside of the
words and the sentences that carry
meaning that we often don't think about.
When we had Lauron Martin on talking
about Martin Luther King Jr., We talked
a lot about procity and and how he was
able to leverage that as as part of the
one of the many things that made his
orations
>> really powerful and meaningful.
>> Absolutely. And and and every language
has its own musicality. That's the
biggest return on investment is
understanding and really working on
proity of the language. Not individual
words, not individual phrases. And if
you've got the pronunciation just right,
you don't need to worry about any of
that. It's really more about the paral
linguistic features, the things outside
the language.
>> Outside the language itself that carry
more meaning that make us relate better
when we're communicating.
>> Right.
>> Can you give me an example or two of
maybe an activity or a thing you would
coach people to do to really touch on
that? I'm going to give some advice that
is often the opposite of what a lot of
speech coaches give and that is to if
you're giving a presentation or if
you're talking over Zoom even to prepare
by recording yourself into a speechtoext
app.
>> Okay?
>> And that speechtoext app will give you a
transcript of what you're saying.
>> Mhm.
>> So you just have to rehearse it once and
then all of a sudden you've got a script
of what you're doing. You can then put
it through AI if you want. You can put
it through AI and say, "I need this to
sound like me still. So keep my syntax,
keep the way that so it sounds authentic
to you." And once you have a script, you
score it
>> and you one of the best techniques that
I can think of is to underline what are
called content or focus words in a
sentence.
>> Okay?
>> If I have the sentence uh for you, um, I
never said you should have hired him. If
I stress a different word, it means
something different. I never said you
should hire him,
>> right?
>> I never said you should I I never said
you should hire him, right? I never said
you should hire him. I never said you
should hire him. Right? Every time you
say the sentence and you put a stress on
a different word, it changes the
context. And if you look at your words
and your your um sentences in your
prepared speech and you start to
underline or bold just those three or
four content words per second and focus
on those words, the meaning of what
you're going to say will come across
regardless of anything else. And so if
you're stressing just those words, all
of a sudden you get a really clear
picture of what's being said. So, that's
one thing that you can do to score your
script for what are called operative or
focus words or content words. The second
thing is to put in slash marks for small
pauses
because people forget to pause when
they're speaking and often times
non-native speakers get told to slow
down.
>> Yes. when that's not always the best
advice. What's more helpful is to take a
sentence and divide it into thought
clusters, groups of speech that have
complete meanings on their own, but
don't often have the punctuation to make
you pause. And these are phrases, simple
phrases in a sentence. Like even when I
was just saying, a thought group is a
group of words that has a complete set
meaning on its own, right? That we don't
give meaning to. And and so when you
break up a sentence into those thought
groups, it becomes easier to understand
and follow. And so putting those slash
marks into a script can help do that.
And then the third way that you can
really help is to provide intonation
assistance in a script in a scoring a
script using sort of downward
inflections, which words to focus on in
different ways, how to use uh
inflections in and we have three basic
inflections in English. the upward where
I'm asking a question,
>> right?
>> The downward where I'm making a
statement and we do that in two
different ways and then the sustained
inflection which I really like which is
so
>> it's all on one note and you're waiting
for me to either go to
>> what's next. Yeah. And when you learn to
incorporate some of those inflections,
you're really tapping into, I think, the
power of the language in ways that that
native speakers are listening to.
>> Paral language, the things that happen
around the the words.
>> That's right.
>> Are so powerful in so many ways. And I
love these activities.
>> Using a script as a tool to help you
plan and prepare your paral language, I
think is beautiful. I love this idea of
getting a transcript of of what you're
saying. Not to say that you're going to
say it exactly that way.
>> That's right.
>> But to begin to look at what are those
words of inflection,
>> of focus, of that that the vocal
highlighting that need to stand out.
>> And this is a tool that I think will
help everybody, not just non-native
speakers.
>> That's right.
>> Thinking about clustering of the key
concepts and how to punctuate them in
terms of pace and rate. Really
important. In fact, I believe they found
some versions of the Declaration of
Independence that had weird marks on
them that they finally concluded were
actually marks for oration that people
would read it. Yes.
>> Because so much of the population at the
time was not able to read. That's right.
So, so giving yourself these little cues
and clues of what to do.
>> And then, and then finally, thinking
about how you end phrases and words.
Many of us will swallow what we say and
get quiet. Some people have up where
everything sounds like a question and
just being able to strategically think
about it and as a question although I I
believe I know the answer.
>> The more you do this the more it becomes
a habit where you don't need to do it.
That's right.
>> You have extensive training in
phonetics. Uh for our listeners who feel
their voice doesn't always carry
authority whether native speaker or not.
What are some vocal adjustments that we
can make to to come across with the
gravitas and and clarity that we look
for?
>> There are so many different things that
we can do. First and foremost, one of
the things that I recommend is to really
understand that I talked about earlier
intonation and how we end sentences. In
English, we do that in two ways. One is
we either step down uh like on the words
uh I'm a professor. [snorts] We notice
we go up on the penultimate sound and
then come down. I'm a professor.
I teach math.
>> And so we either step down or we glide
down at the ends of sentences. And often
times people will swallow their last few
words. Uh they don't end with strength.
And let me talk about what that means.
Uh, and so if you combine the strong
downward inflection in speaking with
slowing down your last few words when
you're done speaking, it signals that
you've completed your thought. It
signals a strength in the end of your
communication and you can use it almost
anytime you're finished speaking to make
sure that people know you've finished
speaking.
>> Yes.
>> And it works really, really well. And
you can either score that on a script
that you've got for a text or you can
think about ending just by slowing down
and using that downward inflection.
>> I I love that technique and I loved how
you role modeled it. Thank you.
[laughter] And we can all record
ourselves a on audio voice memo and
listen to hear how we're doing it and to
become more sensitive to what others are
doing.
>> We can work on these skills through
reading out loud. I often encourage
people reading out loud allows you to
focus on how you're saying something
because the words are right in front of
you. So I'm not saying reading your
script to give a presentation. I'm
saying just read your emails out loud.
Read anything and notice how you can do
that to train your brain.
>> That's right.
>> To be more comfortable doing it.
>> Behind all of it, I believe, is also
this notion of breath and breath
control.
>> That's right.
>> You know, when we get nervous, we
breathe shallow and up. So we have to
remind ourselves that your voice is a
wind instrument
>> and that you have to have the breath
behind it. So I often tell people we
need to build vocal stamina through
breath work as well which could be
reading out loud just
>> becoming aware of where it is.
>> You have provided so much rich
information. Thank you. Before we end,
I'd like to ask you three questions. One
I make up just for you and two I've been
asking everybody for a long time. Are
you up for that? You bet. Excellent.
You created a national curriculum
regarding alcohol abuse and sexual
violence prevention that reached over a
million students. When you're
communicating about such sensitive, high
stakes, and emotionally charged topics,
how do you balance clarity with the
necessity of being empathetic and
concerned? A lot of us uh are in
situations where we have to talk about
emotionally charged issues. What advice
do you have that came from that
experience? And by the way, thank you
for creating a curriculum like that.
It's my pleasure. I was, you know, the
Stanford graduate students actually took
our program, which is great.
>> Um, and and it was throughout, I think
over now 2,000 universities have used
it.
>> Fantastic.
>> And colleges and and it was deeply
important work for me. But you're right,
>> it is very emotionally uh charged. And I
think you have to create first and
foremost is a psychologically safe space
for people to be able to speak. Uh, and
that requires a great empathy and
understanding what happens with trauma.
Once you've created a psychologically
safe space, the goal is to not
retraumatize with your language or to
retraumatize by asking people to
contribute their story when they don't
feel psychologically safe to do so. And
to build in a system of the way that you
communicate that has its foundation in
traumainformed ways of communicating.
And I think that's an incredibly helpful
tool that has empathy at its core. Uh
and that really helps us understand
communicating on a very humanto human
level.
>> So it starts with empathy.
>> It does.
>> Which builds to psychological safety
that then requires some intentional
thought about how to allow for the kind
of dialogue that needs to happen in
these emotionally charged situations
without re-triggering.
>> That's right.
>> Or causing people to become defensive.
Tricky but possible.
>> Tricky but possible. And you also have
to build the structure of all of that
into your policies, into your
procedures. So, it's not just the the
one-on-one communication. It's also the
larger support structure also needs to
be framed that way.
>> Yeah. I like to talk a lot about people,
process, and infrastructure. And you
need all three of those to come together
when you have emotionally charged
issues.
>> Question number two, who's a
communicator that you admire and why?
>> I love Trevor Noah. I [snorts]
think his cultural discussions, his
ability to see
different cultural dynamics and how they
manifest not only from his his native
country and and the way he speaks but to
the US and to Europe and to every place
that he tours and bring he brings
different stories and and he does it in
a way that is enlightening, that is
approachable, that is funny and he has a
lot of humility, believe it or not, in
the way that he communicates do. And so
I think it's u he's one of my favorite
people to listen to. He's got some great
stories around accents. He does take on
some accents sometimes and and talks
about them. But but he's got some really
profound things to say around uh
language and accent and accessibility
and what is considered a standard sound
and what isn't. There is no standard for
English. There are world Englishes. And
I think um Trevor Noah gets to that
really clearly. He is a very engaging
speaker, great storyteller, and he does
a really nice job with some of these
paral language clues and cues that
you're talking about.
>> Final question, what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe?
>> The first is comfort.
>> Yeah, feeling comfortable in being able
to and that's where the psychological
safety I think comes in as well. Um, the
second would be conversational
and this is all delivery by the way.
This isn't content, this is delivery, I
would say. So, the second part is really
making it sound conversational like
you're actually talking to someone, not
talking at someone. Uh, and the third, I
would say, is conviction [snorts]
or people will say confidence, but
having the passion behind what it is
that you're saying. Um, so that you're
making a connection that that is
important to you.
>> I love things that are easy to remember.
the three C's, comfort, conversational,
conviction.
>> That's right.
>> And those are all helped by the
techniques that you have taught us and
that you teach on a regular basis.
Peter, thank you so much for your time.
I appreciate you highlighting the value
that people who speak another language
bring and the tools that can help all of
us feel more comfortable in our
communication. Thank you. Thank you so
much, Matt. It was great being here.
>> Thank you for joining us for another
episode of Think Fast, Talks Smart, the
podcast. To learn more about
communication best practices, please
listen to episode 82 with Nancy Dwarte.
This episode was produced by Katherine
Reed, Ryan Campos, and me, Matt
Abrahams. Our music is from Floyd Wonder
with special thanks to the Podium
Podcast Company. Please find us on
YouTube and wherever you get your
podcasts. Be sure to subscribe and rate
us. Also, follow us on LinkedIn, Tik
Tok, and Instagram, and check out
fastermarter.io io for deep dive videos,
English language learning content, and
our newsletter. Please consider our
premium offering for extended deepthinks
episodes, AMAs, and much more at
faster.io/premium.
You'll also find value by joining our
thinkf fast talksmarting community at
faster.io/arning.
You'll find video lessons, learning
quest, discussion boards, my AI coach,
and book club opportunities. Again,
that's faster.io/arning io/arning to
become part of our ThinkFast, Talks
Smart Learning community.